what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know we have a lot of new
subscribers on the channel and we go
live every wednesday thursday and
saturday at the same time 9 30 i know
we're a little late today but you know
before i start guys do not forget our
channel sponsor is cooking with chris
guys i'm down 20 pounds on this meal
plan he makes a customized meal plan
just for
you okay literally you give this guy the
foods you already like to eat he makes
you a meal plan and it's so easy like i
could not lose 20 pounds for the longest
and it like comes off like that so the
link to that is in the description it
helps support the show
on top of that if you guys send super
chats um
they will be read during the stream so
send a super chat help support the show
um and we'll read them during the stream
okay guys so today we have some special
guests why don't we go around to your
name your age your relationship status
and where you are from
my name is ollie
relationship status and where you're
from my name is ollie i'm 21 21 right
now i'm not 27.
in my head in my head i'm still young
i am single and i am from southwest
london
well i'm marcia i'm from portugal i'm 28
and i'm single
yeah did i say that twice no no you're
good you're good in my mind then
my name is troy um i'm 22.
i'm single
i'm living in east london at the moment
uh i'm parva i'm 20.
i'm persian and i'm single
my name is tj 27 i'm in the streets
okay
it's the same word
and the streets are calling yeah
okay um so guys um have you guys so the
topic today is fresh and fit
um they had a clip that went viral
recently
and um first off do you guys know who
fresh and fit is yeah yeah no okay now
i've seen a couple videos here um okay
so they're they're in a sector of
youtube it's called the manosphere and
it's basically like men's content so
it's like self-improvement dating advice
it's all like for men
um and they had a clip go viral recently
that
um where myron one of the hosts was
saying
it is cheating if a girl has an
instagram when she's in a relationship
um
but don't worry the men the men can have
an instagram though that's not cheating
and okay so the reason being is because
when you have social media on some level
you're looking for attention right
on some level you're looking for
attention from someone otherwise you
wouldn't post yes no i agree
i have to agree with that no i i think
you
i love taking pictures
i do i love being creative but at the
end of the day if you have a crush on
someone
you post that one story for them to view
it oh we've all done that yeah you dress
up cute you do a little
we can't we can't yeah yeah we don't
well you post that one like pretty
picture for him to be like
well my ex doesn't have he does i have
instagram though but i blocked him for
example and i do love to take pictures
but i don't do
in order to i don't know trigger him or
tease him yeah or like to get attention
i do love photos i do love myself i
actually this probably sounds
a little bit
ego or
narcissist oh exactly i spend way more
time looking at my pictures than
actually other people mm-hmm
i actually i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
who pays attention to me yeah i actually
just like but then whatever i like to
see my profile like looking good you
know and that's it then but then why
post it at all and you can just keep
them in your camera roll yeah exactly
but i just like feel
a bit more like i can show to my friends
for example my instagram is pro it's
private yeah so i only accept people
that i want to
they i mean to be you know be there yeah
see right i want to share
even though it's just people i met once
i feel okay it's a good vibe it's a you
know i will keep it but it's not in
order to get attention i feel like
i like it but it's literally for
attention because you're getting
attention it's getting attention from
people you know it might be a smaller
group yeah it can be it can be a very
like you said a small amount of group
but at the end of the day if it was just
for your eyes only yeah
you got it yeah yeah i think that's what
she's trying to say about like likes you
know no that's something else that's
more followers
it's just it's
yeah
that's right yes
so the question i have for you guys um
is
do you think having an instagram is
cheating to start no no
no it gives you the opportunity to okay
but everything gives you the opportunity
to cheat walking taking the tube gives
you an opportunity to cheat
not really not really
i feel like or not i don't feel like i
think i think
instagram has two has two
nowadays has like two main purposes
business or dating facts the reality is
so if if you're a girl
how many people have tried to slide in
your dms
how many of you guys have swiped up on a
story you know exactly
it left the fire emoji or the heart or
something or like i mean just like
there's or it's either you're promoting
your business
or at some stage someone is going to
move to you or you're going to move to
someone else so i feel like
yeah instagram is one of one of those
two things so
it offers you the opportunity to it's
kind it's kind of like you're selling
yourself like it's like your online
portfolio like your representation of
yourself like so you're sharing your
good parts like you're showing yourself
looking your best for other people
that's basically it though yeah no for
for attention for other people to view
it
so no but we were talking about the
other day where like instagram and
everything like it's actually a social
currency now like even when you go out
on stuff
and the more followers you have the more
like you can do the easier to get into
things
yeah 100 is that element of it the
business element but as a girl if your
instagram's open and it's not private
like you want the attention if you're
not doing if you're not if you're not
trying to like sell something towards a
business or like do something i feel
like it's for attention
a little bit i think it's a great way to
have an instagram even if it's open or
private i mean when it's open of course
i think you have way more specific
possibilities you know to create a
business to share and to create more
following definitely
uh some i don't think is like the main
reason is like to like to create an
instagram is to she i sorry to cheat no
[ __ ]
but
i mean
uh i think you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
and portuguese guys don't judge me
there was cheating before instagram
before social media before internet i i
think even my parents i don't know if
they cheat but you know even that
happened before but without internet
without you know uh smartphones it was
like a nokia the snake game you know
that's it
but i think what he was trying to say i
agree with you that's what i said as
well but i think it gives you an outlet
to do it easier yeah we have
i think all of us have experienced
someone being in a relationship posting
it and then they swipe up on your story
yeah you're like
what
well i think it just gives you that
interesting stat
one and three affairs that cause a
divorce are from social media exactly
yeah
yeah one and three
there we go so i feel like social media
has made it harder for relationships to
work because you're as you're as a guy
you're seeing all these beautiful girls
on your timeline
constantly you're gonna be tempting
you're like oh there's more beautiful
girls out there you're seeing all these
girls
so you're so it's like it's tempting you
and you're seeing that every day
constantly constantly you're like oh
yeah i think it works both ways as well
though because as a guy
like back in the day you were just
obviously before social media if you
were just competing with the guys that
went to your school or the guys in your
area and now you're competing with
people from america that have yachts
people who have
planes
like and you're just here like i'm
making off but like oh i ain't got new
york do you know what no you go you go
first the amount of girls i know so like
that aren't that aren't the
the greatest looking in the world like
just normal yeah that have
a bunch of blue tick guys i'm talking
i'm not going to bait out teams but a
lot of fun
wow i've gone through the request
literally so a lot of people i have a
question i have a question is it because
she
while she looks
average in real life on her instagram
it's so edited she looks above average
yeah instagrams are like not like so
edited just she reveals
she's like a good body catfish catfish
nah she's a decent body but she's not
wearing a lot yeah yeah so it's kind of
screaming like easy
i don't know what you're talking
i think some people they feel like they
think like some women they show too much
it's because they want they are weak and
they are insecure and they are trying to
you know call some attention
but i don't think so like some people
maybe some other people not i think it's
all about who you are in the end of the
day because sometimes i met a few people
they look so wow
on instagram and then you meet them and
they are very humble they are very
confident like confident
you know and they are not at all what
you think yeah but i
i think that
if you're posting your body on instagram
it's a hundred percent for attention
like there is nothing else that it is
for
you what you want validation for your
body i'm not
i'm not above it
i understand where you're coming from
and half of it is 100 thought right i
think also when you're like um happy
with something or proud of it like proud
of the work have you done and like the
progress you made yeah you do but
absolutely for people to see it or else
it would have been staying in your
camera i agree yeah but i think also to
show that you're like proud of it yeah
so thank you so other question when
on social media
what do you guys consider cheating i'm
going to give you a couple examples
this is fun so guys liking instagram
models bikini pictures
i mean that's not cheating no it's it's
not cheating but it's like why was that
necessary
but if you it's not cheating oh yeah
like i was cheating but it's just kind
of moist
why are you doing it but if you saw like
a male
would you no because i was like why
would i do it but i understand it's not
cheating you think um
i wouldn't it's like it's okay for the
guys out there that do that like why
yeah exactly
yeah on the guy's part it's just thirsty
and it's it's a bit moist yeah yeah it's
a bit moist like you shouldn't yeah
there's no point in doing that just look
let's go that's it yeah yeah i think we
all have eyes and we appreciate
beautiful things it's human so if i see
a guy that is pretty and he looks good
and he looks hot even on the street i
mean i'm not going to be like like on
him but
if i see on instagram why not you know
like even if you're in a relationship
yeah i feel like at least i can see if
my partner is confident and if you trust
me because
there's a trouble on that that i will
say okay my partner doesn't trust me and
my partner is insecure and i'm i'm not
up to that
you know i think everyone has
insecurities but you should not
um
how do you say mirror
those insecurities
wait did you say that again so what
makes them insecure
like me liking someone who's
not liking how would you say me thinking
that someone is beautiful it's okay to
see right she's beautiful right he's
beautiful yeah but that's something else
though that's something completely else
that's just appreciating that people are
like yeah but i think there's a
difference between looking at someone
and interacting with it i think that's
sending them a message exactly
it's the message you're sending no no
but i like like i think
it's it's like baby steps you know what
i mean like it starts it starts
for him to like because most the time
nowadays i feel like especially girls on
instagram their way of shooting their
shot is they just like one or two of
your photos boys as well men as well
some guys will follow the girl if you're
like if you're like if you're about that
life you just lack a few and just see
what happens in it but here's the thing
because usually nine times out of ten
the man is pursuing
the like
if if a guy likes a girl's photo
she's
most the time she's not gonna then jump
in his dm's most of the time he might
like it back and wait for him to do it
if the girl likes the guy's picture
that's that's an invitation that's yeah
that's that's a golden ticket slide in
please yeah yeah so
yeah so the guys so girls yeah they'll
like two or three photos and that's when
you know that's when you slide in yeah
that's when you know that's when you
know that's like this especially if
you've just posted a photo and you
they've just liked it that's nothing but
if you haven't posted anything in a
couple weeks they've gone on your page
they've gone through your photos
like it might not even be the most
recent free it might be they've scrolled
through liked a couple photos what if
what if they because that's the new
thing like liking instagram stories do
you guys think that's also an invitation
to slide instagram story
like if you like instagram stories
[Music]
do you know a good thing about that as
well no one can see the light
that's a really good point
sometimes sometimes it disappears after
24 anyways because sometimes you might
click on you might click on a photo you
might look through the likes see who are
who's liked it as one of my boys liked
it but stories you can't do that so
yeah
so
so what okay so what about swiping up on
someone's story yeah is that cheating is
that okay okay
is that cheating but you know the person
if you know the point but as in does he
swipe up and he's like oh have a good
workout or is it okay let's say let's
say you you have um an acquaintance that
both of both of you know okay the guy
you and the guy right
and he swipes up on our stories how do
you know if it like is it ever friendly
no is it always not dirty
it is flirty what about guys what do you
think
so can you repeat that
okay so say say um
okay say me and you are dating right
and you and i'm your mutual oh yeah
we're the mutual friend
you always are swiping up on her story
but like we
both is it ever friendly
if i'm always doing it there's there's
an under there's probably an underlying
exactly yeah
like i said if he's just like oh do you
know when or was the movie good was this
good like what that's that's fine we're
like reacting
to the picture where she looks fine
yeah
how do you think
social media
has influenced women's standards
and men's oh a lot i think social media
in general just change relationships
because
you're seeing all these instagram models
and it's not real like nothing's real
really
and so
that's their like you're at home with
your girl or your man or whatever you're
seeing all these models on that and
they're like they might be liking your
stuff dmnu and stuff so it's just like
oh i could get that
but then
when you meet him in real life it's not
the same so that's that the standards
have just
risen and it's so sad because it creates
a competition between the partners and
there should be no competition
but it should be like
it's like violent valentine's day people
post process stuff oh i've got this
massive teddy i've got all these
chocolates
like
and sometimes it's fake it's not easy
yeah you just put you're just doing it
to prove oh my boyfriend likes me more
than your boyfriend likes you or
whatever it's like a competition it's
true if you really love it it's like an
ego thing
yeah yes
there we go thanks
for times of valentine's day that's when
you find out everyone's got a booty as
well
this whole time that you had a man the
whole time literally crazy i think the
problem is like people think the
the grass is greener in the other side
you know and then they realize and
they're like [ __ ] it's not and then they
go back and they go back but it's too
late they think they can just do enough
then to you know accept them you're like
but who do you think does that more men
or women i think women men men come on
men 100 percent
i'm gonna give you guys some stats okay
women so oh she's gonna say women what
because
so
when it comes to divorce um women file
for divorce 70 percent of the time but
that's and college educated women it's
90
second thing is um
20 of men have access to 80 of women so
the reason that women think all men are
players is because they're all sleeping
with the same ones
the majority one in three men under
third one and three men under 30 years
proud to be part of that 20.
so one in three men under 30 are virgins
um and i'm gonna give you an example so
so for me right i'm i'm five eleven and
a half i'm close to six foot right i
prefer guys to my height or taller right
or close to my height but let's say i
wanted six foot or taller i'm six or
five smaller
um that that's only 15 percent of guys
on top of that if you have a specific
type
so
you've got a small category to pick
through right so and let's say i want a
guy that makes more money than i do and
is more driven than i am that's an even
smaller percentage so again the reason
like women think men are players is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones
yeah
and
because yeah and then men are men are
dogs so they will just sleep with anyone
so you think so you'll sleep with anyone
no i've got
guys guys will sleep with girls and it's
not it's not a big thing but girls
they're like so selective like as we
should be like i should be but the more
picky we are the more
the less we find a good choice sometimes
you know sometimes you are so picky we
just actually like choose the player the
wrong one the wrong one well and then we
we get stuck no you know what it's our
fault because we have we have the
beautiful guy in front of us and he's
giving you everything you want but
you're like that's not enough well it's
because a lot of times because we don't
like too good but we don't like two
batteries no no it's because a lot of
times attraction cues so the same the
same attraction cues that make the guy
the hero makes him the villain so you
ever wonder why those girls stay with
that guy that's so aggressive and just
hits walls and you're like what is wrong
with this [ __ ] like why are you still
with him it's because like she knows he
can protect her
so like aggression is attractive to us
because the hero has to be expected she
can attack her as well what okay no but
that's that's why you see women stay a
lot of times in abusive relationships
yeah like because at like i mean
obviously no girl is attracted to a guy
beating the [ __ ] out of her but that
that trait the that's a masculine trait
yes and like women are attracted to
dominance and you're also attracted to
men that other women want because it's a
form of pre-selection so like back in
the day if you saw a guy that that had a
lot of girls around that that was an
indication that he could take care of
them like social proof is very important
to women in dating like that's why you
see guys with check marks just get
like ugly guys
get a little bit of fame they get they
get a model
like that
so girls always just gonna go for trash
men basically
pretty much no
well
hope not it's like a never ending psycho
well it kind of it kind of depends
because a woman a woman would go through
phases
so like under the age of like 27
women um tend to go for like the bad boy
the player but as they see their looks
like starting to run out basically they
have to pick a guy
that's a better bet
yeah no because like as as women get
older like you have less like um your
options
cut in half by the time you're 30 as a
woman based on like dating app a data
i actually had like a great guy for
seven years
and he wanted to marry me and then i
moved to london
and then i met this
he's a good guy but he's toxic if that
makes sense he's a player
and yeah i feel like we are quite
attractive to players because i feel
there is like some narcissist
uh traits or not even as women
that we need
to fix
sometimes i do believe like we attract
where we are in a way yeah and if we
attract someone who's a player it's
because you play yourself as well in a
way and you meet that person in order to
fix some narcissistic traits within you
and you guys gonna mirror like each
other you know i do think like have you
ever asked that recently have you ever
met those people that are like in toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
after toxic relationship but it's never
them
they are never the problem but there
just happened to be the common
denominator do you know i think that
comes from wanting to fixing people and
thinking that you can fix their problems
i think that's the way women kind of
avoid accountability for their part yes
they ignore their own things and then
they well no no i think women oftentimes
what i've seen is like women will say oh
i'm a fixer and like kind of make it
seem like they're the good one the guy's
the bad one they're just trying to fix
him but really like they have some toxic
traits too and they don't admit to it i
think we all do but don't try to fix no
one like fixtures it doesn't work it
doesn't work i don't know as women we
are like the nurturer and the the man is
the provider and as a woman like we have
the tendency tendency of like being you
know like smothering you know giving the
love like fixing helping nurturing
but we have to stop with that with men
we have to stop
with our children
cause they get a tantrum and they get
spoiled and they do whatever and they
play you and then you feel like oh my
god i give so much it is true i don't
want to give like their car yeah but
that's my mouth oh my gosh but that's
not the that's the exception that is not
the norm oh come on come on like you
want to that'll go to south west london
okay okay let me let me let me ask the
guys let me let me let me ask my friend
my friend i leave with her
i leave with her and that happened to
her okay
she lost her car
okay okay but anything in general who
spends more money on the opposite gender
guys men are women obviously men yeah
yeah we're depends actually depends it
depends actually it's very dependent it
depends
it depends it depends my friend
she was earning way more
and he was no job he had no job at all
he was like doing drugs you know like
player laughs what is she doing
exactly
i'm sorry
and he was good looking you know and
then there's
there's the fun of it i agree with her
there's a lot of people i know that are
in that studio
exactly there's a lot of people there
that's rather that's rare usually
it's not it's not that rare
how many times have you seen a guy yeah
in the passenger seat no
on the average relationship the guy's
gonna be paying for the for the for the
dates he's gonna be
like men earn more women
guys are in the top 10 15 of like looks
wise that's the only reason they can get
away with it 100 percent
i feel like
there's a lot of roman that get away
with it there's a lot of what road man
roadman
on the streets you know what i mean like
the shot and stuff gangbangers
yeah i know but are they are they like
good looking they're
not i mean i'm not gonna say
yeah but i think i think at a certain
age girls find that attractive yeah yeah
from like 17 i would say 15 to 17 15 to
seven
15 to like 20. ah maybe
i i could never find that one it's the
same
things she was saying like girls are
attracted to
to bad boys or people
who are like doing wrong because
seen as like um like they're alpha male
or they're you know
dominant dominant yeah they like they
like
they're attracted to the badness because
it's like oh it's exciting you can't be
alpha male in the tech fleece in the
scooter so i don't understand what
they're trying to boom
it's like the bad boy thing like they
like i don't know they like it's a bit
of edgy but then they'll do that and
then they'll complain yeah yeah down the
line that old men are trash but it's
it's it's yours i don't understand how
you can complain that men are trash if
you're the one selecting because women
women decide women who have sex that's
what i mean it's literally you decide
it's only you
you all make no choice so it's like if
you're if you're picking the wrong men
like you can't blame the guys the other
guys because it's like bro we don't well
one in three men under 30 are virgins
that's what i'm saying it's the
exception rather than that
i i want to say it's in the us but
usually the trends are very simple so so
usually yeah go ahead one two three
do you guys think that
like a guy can ruin a girl for later
what what do you mean like ruin her like
like
no
like she dates a bad boy and he kind of
ruins that girl forever absolutely oh of
course 100 that's yeah 100
yeah why oh my gosh why because not
enough people go to therapy
and therapy is expensive
sometimes so yeah
and not everyone can afford so after
like you are in a relationship with
someone who's toxic you get trauma and
trauma is not easy to get rid of it i
got it
um i'm
i am one of them honestly but i'm doing
therapy by myself to myself every day
i'm checking out on myself
and it's good to be aware and it's
important to talk about it because that
really happens
and i think it happens as well like
there's women
toxic women who
does to other men
that too you know but
i feel it's it's important to know when
to let go because otherwise you end up i
don't know pregnant and then
you you know some people they they go to
these kind of
relationships and it ends really bad
okay i'm gonna read super chat really
quick so um we got a super chat from
foot lfc i used to love fresh and fit
but quickly realize they cap way too
much and don't practice what they teach
pearly i love this channel though you
keep it 100. thank you
um also guys all super chats are going
towards um
a
and we have a second camera now
[Laughter]
[Music]
um okay wait what was the next thing we
were gonna buy
oh my gosh it's like a camera switcher
thing it's like a i don't know what it's
called
a10 mini yeah that's that's her we have
a producer now but he knows what it's
called in eight times
i'll get a camera for myself at some
point yeah and we're gonna get um a
camera there and then like a third
camera angle so yeah okay
um
okay what's what's funny i want to be in
on the joke
what's that it's just true in general
what's the i want to be in on it it's
literally just true as a person it's his
personality it's okay
okay
okay question who do you think who do
you think cheats more men or women and
do they oh she's gonna hit us with
statistics
who do you think cheats more men or
women and do they cheat differently i
think we cheat differently i think men
cheat more okay but we definitely cheat
differently like i feel like and i know
it's gonna sound bad but when women
cheat is worse yeah i was gonna say that
i knew you guys would say that their
argument is because when the girl cheats
it's because she has feelings for him
he's providing something
but that's usually what it is it's about
like it's about emotion it's about on
top of that like as a girl when a guy
sleeps with a girl he just sleeps with
her you can you can just like you can
literally sleep with her even worse
when you guys that's not worse that is
not worth it if i got she didn't open up
your book you took
like if you were to cheat would you
cheat with someone other than your
boyfriend
no
there we go oh wait it depends
i'm sorry
depends on this no i was gonna say
so you're the first thing you see is
someone's attractiveness obviously but i
think if someone's
not better looking than your boyfriend
necessarily but he provides you with
something else emotionally you get more
attractive
you're
that's the point they're making is the
guy has something your boyfriend doesn't
does it
where a girl like like okay i always say
this like do you remember the day you
realized you had to worry about ugly
[ __ ] too
[Laughter]
you said it
look it like i was like you thought
but it's because like guys it's more of
like an instinct they're like oh god
boop like
boobs bump like ass i don't even like
see what she looks like
i didn't even notice she was fat like
like that's what i'm saying like guys
it's more of just like an immediate
response where girls like we have to
connect with them on some level we have
some prerequisite for them sleeping with
us
it takes a while for a girl i think men
like have you ever have any of you ever
slept with a girl that you would never
want to be seen in public with yes
no no no i said that as a joke back me
how good are my standards
impeccable all my girls are top three
pickleball they're always top three
they're always set free
on my heart i'll put it there friendship
everyone has their person that you would
the world can never know about
[Music]
okay what about you guys
i haven't to be fair i'm like my man
i've got he knows i know like i was
saying earlier like there are guys that
are dogs that they will just sleep with
anything just
just because they can or try and get
their numbers up at uel name them
[Laughter]
don't be shy go ahead let's go ahead
yeah there's guys obviously
they'll just sleep with girls at uni
just because they know or they know
she's easy like they're bored or they're
like horny or whatever they'll just
sleep with her
but yeah like girls aren't going to do
that
or less likely to anyways
do i think for guys like
that behavior usually
i'll say okay there are two types of
guys the guys that have like could get
girls from a young enough age and the
really really super late bloomer so i
feel like you always go for a phase
where it's like you're just you don't
just go for it
and then usually
that that that phase usually ends like
after uni whatever and then you're just
in life and you and you you can turn
down sex
whereas those guys
who are super late bloomers are the ones
that like in their mid-20s and they're
just like they will literally go
anywhere and do anything and it's just
like it's the ones that got like they
had no girls at school and suddenly like
they're attractive now they start
hitting gym or whatever they can
suddenly get loads of girls and then
they just like don't know how to like
control it like what's composure
i said one thing i was like how do you
expect to play champions league games if
you don't play pre-season
all right so you gotta build your levels
up you gotta listen
are you okay wait can i can i clarify
let me just understand so crazy so you
gotta sleep with the uglier girls to get
to the hotter girls not to get to go but
if you're not on form
okay so like that's so like so you guys
are practicing i can't relate
so the ugly girls are like practice
not not me that's like it's like a
friend
it's like someone else that'd be bad
i would never
am i wrong no okay when i was like a
younger like yeah
it's all coming
[Laughter]
okay um
so okay
do you guys think that
um because we were kind of talking about
how cheating is different for men and
for women right
um and i want to tie this back into
social media okay
do you think that it's cheating if a
girl's posting
ass pictures on the internet in a
relationship 100 that's cheating yeah
i wouldn't say cheating cheating is like
a strong word i'd say that yeah
i feel like it's disrespectful or like
yes she's overstepped her boundary i
wouldn't say like
she's cheating i think if that issue
you're air sorry no you show your ass on
the beach you know and then
what's the problem
that's the thing i know it's a very
thick
about sharing it on instagram it's
calling for attention but then you again
you are proud of your body you want to
show it if you are over showing okay
that that recalls like for attention
like you're over posting about your ass
about your boobs about your body all the
time i get it but if you're sharing like
a bikini or a lingerie photos just you
know once in a while what's the problem
with that you are like you are proud
i think it i think it's just i think but
i think it just screams easy to me
to me it's like girls they are easy in
real life if there's a thing where you
like do gym and stuff and like your
personal training like obviously you
work for your bum and that's fair enough
in it because that's part of your brand
your business if you're just any normal
girl and you're posting a picture of
your nash then listen
yes
like why are you posting a picture of
your of your behind like that's
disrespectful
that's an open invitation for hella dms
hello
story replies like i'm paying for a
premium account
no but like i feel like
girls often times mistake sexual
attention with like relationship
attention because like they'll put this
ass picture on the internet one that's
going to be there forever like your kids
like are going to see that someday is
that that what if a guy posts like a
topless pic or something when he's in a
relationship if a guy does it if a guy
does it i mean okay
it's twofold right one yeah i don't
think i i do think it is i do think it's
i do think it's kind of douchey wait to
be honest yeah
um but honestly i think it's a double
standard yes i think it's more cheating
for women than it is for men because
most men aren't going to get girls in
their like dms like that and i think if
you're a guy and you're posting a
topless picture there's one or two
things i have a hench because you've
actually worked for it so it's just like
fair enough like you might be a
bodybuilder or whatever the hell or
you're like hella tired and it's just
like it's art not art but you know what
i mean you're trying to change your
tattoos but you still wanna you're still
on attention like you guys
okay okay it's not the same because
girls don't really
see like a chest and are like i want to
have sex with that like
like guys guys see an ass and like
the
you know it's it's wait so so
you post it you might get like 20 30
replies i don't know how many i posted
like a chess but you might get one or
two if that
you know what i mean
that down to the fact that we're we're
always the ones pursuing whatever
whatever you do will lead to more than
what if we do something because i'm
gonna make that first move
yeah because guys usually are moving to
girls rather than girls move into guys
yeah we're we're the salespeople yeah
love averages you gotta move to anyway
let me know
but i think like uh women are seen as
more as a sexual um
than men that's why in general let's
start there but if i see like a male
as a model like a really nice model and
i see and i like his body
you can actually get turned like in a
way like
sexy yeah i would do him why not like no
but
like he crosses your mind sometimes he
does it's not just like as a yeah but
okay okay but it crosses your mind
sometimes it does right but that's
that's of course they see boobs and and
above they're like ah you know oh my god
i'll go there i would dive in i mean
like guys have a thing such as like a
sex doll
that's the thing that men purchase six
doll
dolls yeah yeah like a girl would never
buy that
yeah but you don't buy your little toys
and stuff
but yeah yeah girls have way more you
live with me you know i don't have one
no but i'm saying like men are more
attracted to like a body like that's
what i'm saying like why do they need
that visual because like men are more
attracted to like
like they're more visual than women yeah
sure
i mean who
who's gone for a guy that's ugly but
funny
no oh just
yeah
women fall in love with what they hear
and fall in love with what they see
that's why i feel like it's a double
standard and it's different for men and
for women
[Laughter]
okay so um
do you think in a marriage it would be
better if both partners just deleted
social media if you really want to be
married for a long time i was going to
say i think like it would cause less
stress like maybe not instagram because
you can use that for business or twitter
but like snapchat like why would you
need like your friends can text you you
don't need stuff like that
when you're in a relationship why do you
have snapchat yeah if you have snapchat
you are in the streets sorry
if you have snapchats
me i deleted it because
nothing good comes from snapchat i
re-downloaded it
i mean i just got it
you know i mean
designed for secrecy like what good can
come oh my god i need to tell you what
you know you can download the data from
a snapchat and get every single message
that someone has sent or received ah how
how
don't ask me don't ask me don't ask me
how i know how do you do it how do you
do that um can you like after the show
wait can i just see my old messages or
troy's messages both if you well if you
know his passcode for no reason
wow
i would never do that that'd be like
crazy every like
you can see every single message that
they've ever posted
yeah like i i did it
i mean i never um did that
no no but i know it what no i saw it on
tick-tock and i was like oh cool did it
actually work
[Laughter]
anyways i'm single now
um no but
yeah i agree snapchat i think in general
is kind of
just rather yeah delete in social media
just give
just make it easier so you're not
tempted or there's no
jealousy things like that i mean you can
keep facebook nothing bad happens on
facebook it's just a bunch of like one
who still used to be surprised bro
yeah you'd be surprised
and one of the number one like um there
was a divorce lawyer that talked about
um one of like way that couples get
divorced after like 20 30 years is
because they get a friend request from
like a high school ex
and then they they leave the
relationship for it and then they
remember all the reasons they broke up
20 years ago yeah with the x
and then they they both end up single
you get by then
[Music]
i think social media is just
i i don't know like
maybe some social medias don't really
what's that's on twitter i'm not sure if
you know but
i think twitter is like a social media
site where
nothing that bad happens like who moves
to people on twitter i feel like if you
take away one
then it'll just
it'll just transfer into it all social
media platforms are all copying each
other like even twitter has stories like
they all like they're all basically the
same like when something goes well like
the tick tock scrolling thing they have
that on snapchat on instagram like they
all just start copying each other
like what's popping well and the other
thing is i think social media has raised
women's standards a lot because like
they'll get messages from guys that they
would never get approached by in real
life not even i was gonna say he was
talking about it earlier but
girls can lit it's insane you see these
people on tv and they're big you get you
can literally just dm them and they will
dm you back not like is that happening
to you
hey yo yeah
name them
100 thousand followers years of time
nba yes or no any nba players yeah i'll
say yesterday
okay nfl
no no
what about an actor any famous actors
yes really just not
okay okay okay all right
wait
[Music]
wait wait
omg what the
he dmu
or did i it's 2019. i think iceland oh
okay and we followed each other for a
while oh wow okay
they won't see they won't see um
that's
that's crazy but that's um the point is
it's very everything happens on social
media like it's so
easy nowadays you see these people and
you're like oh i could never get in
touch with them
and then suddenly you're in touch with
them so do you take that because okay
i've i've um
i did an experiment actually where for a
video where i dm'd 50 um nba players to
just see if any would respond okay and
you guys can watch it on my channel go
help me get my watch time up um please
there's like two or three that responded
but it's interesting because to me i'm
like
i would never consider that to be like
real because like i know he's just
trying to sleep with me
like i like you're not but you still had
a reply for him didn't you
think that's insane yeah but i just
i don't know like to me it doesn't
really mean anything because i feel like
those guys just do that do that with
with to everyone like you just have to
be half good looking and they'll
whatever but it's not like they want
anything from you they just i mean what
are your ads of locking down an nba
player good luck
even the why even the girlfriends like
you have to share them basically
actually you know what i mean
yeah but this is
sorry
i was gonna say again oh [ __ ] you just
left me
yeah that's okay
oh no it was on your point actually yeah
so yeah and this is why i think that
cheating
is worse than what's easier for women to
cheat than it is for men
yeah on social media that is because
you said like these high-profile people
would reply to both of you yeah but if
any of us were to
dm
like these verified instagram models the
chances of them replying to us purely
because we don't have a
blue tick
on social media is
basically zero agreed
do you think that cheating is different
for men and for women
like do you think do you because there's
some people in the manosphere that think
that
if a guy cheats you should try to work
it out because it could have just meant
nothing to him
but if a girl cheats it's the
relationship is over but that's what
we're talking about though for me if a
guy cheats on me it's over there is no
way
to come back this is going to sound
really wild though yeah
but like when a guy cheats the girl is
never better looking than his girlfriend
and this is the point i was going to
make before
because the guy doesn't want to the guy
doesn't actually want to he says it's
going to sound so mad the guy doesn't
actually want to leave his girlfriend he
doesn't want to fall in love with
another girl he act in a weird way most
i'm
not those toxic on what is toxic but not
those like weird ones but like um the
abusive ones but like in a weird way
the guy still loves his girlfriend and
in the back of his mind he doesn't
actually want to leave her or fall in
love with someone else so the girl he
cheats on is usually never as good as
his actual girlfriend if that makes
sense
yeah go because girls would be more
likely to
now if he was a guy you would end the
relationship and then get with the girl
you wouldn't but we don't if you if she
was if she was better but we don't end
relationships yeah guys
guys settle
and and that's the worst thing i feel
like girls when they cheat tell me if
i'm wrong but they do it in such a
twisted way like i know so many girls
that will like sleep with
guys friends after they like broke up or
if they're seeing each other in a little
break you know what i mean guys don't do
that [ __ ] because it's just like bro i'm
not going to sleep with your broker bro
code this one
you're never gonna bring that girl in
the same room as the girl you cheated
with a girl who literally walks you in
makes you spud this guy chill play fifa
and and
you will never know i just had to say
one thing you said broco and that could
happen both ways
a guy's not going to risk it because
they're risky
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true that's
true
very true
i've done that but
now if a guy if a guy slides in my dms
and i see on his profile he has a
girlfriend just send it to her
oh as you should
we should sleep
we should start snitching but you guys
don't stitch because you don't care
no no no we just we just don't snitch
it's like it's just like because if a
nice girl slides your dm but then she's
got a guy
if you snitch and it's going to mess it
up so you just be like just chill until
she doesn't have a guy and then
come back
but broco doesn't exist anymore
no it
unwritten rules like yeah if you're my
guys and you've like you're in a
relationship with a girl you end it and
then she's trying to move to you
even if you find a mad attractive you're
not going to be like you still haven't
you're going to tell your boy that now
but then
if it's a random guy you don't know then
there's no bro code
he's saying if it's like your homie
uh-huh they wouldn't i promise you that
i wouldn't oh my god some experience
like they will
oh my god no they'll be they'll be in
your dm's then yes yes
the next day it's over now
and their friends their friends will
flirt with you too in front of the guy i
swear to god
i'm about to just
thank you
that's happening
that's not women don't know about it's
either sometimes it's not a boy but the
majority of the time it's because that
guy has pressed triangle and given the
through ball and you don't even know
he's literally one chest pass
if you haven't seen it no look past and
in the guys that you've given his
blessing yeah yeah for the other guy to
literally make his move so
sometimes i've got like a goal be like
oh my god your boy is doing this and
it's
like
i know
and it's it's mad as well guys yesterday
the girlfriends are like you i got with
your boy and he's not even telling you
anything but like you're the you're the
one that assisted your bro yeah you said
you gave him the green light he's like
yeah
yeah
friend good job good boy okay i will say
with cheating okay if a guy cheats on me
now
i'm gonna leave right and the reason
being is because
i feel like we're not even married yet
like okay if you're doing it now like
the future can't be bright right but i
think if you have a child it's not about
you anymore
so if i had a kid with someone i would
try to work it out yeah because i think
like like your feelings are kind of
irrelevant when you have a kid and i
would never want to put a kid at a st
like at every like that's how do you put
it sorry um at a disadvantage for their
life and like a kid is at every
statistical disadvantage if they don't
have both parents in the home like
they're more like 80 of people in prison
we're born from a single parent home
um
about i mean i'm a nanny i work as a
nanny for 10 years and i've seen um a
lot of kind of different families single
mothers both parents
and i came from i mean my mom is single
and she raised me i i had no father
present in my life and
that was good i think because he cheated
on my he my father cheated on my mom so
and she needed she never wanted to work
out and i think that's best because if
you don't trust the person then in the
back of your head you're gonna always
have trust issues and then those stress
issues that will
um you know lead in your head
like to travel like
in the house and
for this child like to see the parents
like fighting all the time for little
things because they don't trust each
other well but that's why that's how you
like go to therapy and like find other
ways to work it out and afford
i mean therapy yeah i just everyone can
have that luxury you know to have
therapy or to have people around them
and to support them because we are you
know
we're not all coming from the same place
right yeah but like even
like before the invention of like birth
control like honestly people stayed
together through thick and thin
people didn't just leave like like there
were so many times where the grandpa had
like a a family on the other side of
town nobody knew about
yeah but that was before instagram right
because now these days
you know they always see and the better
option they go so you know don't work on
they don't and it's not i just i just
think like at the end of the day it's
not about you when you have children
like like like why would you want to put
your kid at that disadvantage like i i
know getting cheated on is terrible like
that's a whole like that is the worst
feeling in the world like you feel like
absolute [ __ ] but like at the end of the
day if i had kids like it's not about me
it's not about my feelings
it's about the kids go ahead so if your
your partner cheated on you when you had
kids you would stay with them
but how many times let's say cheated on
you 10 times and you caught him i do
there has to be like a limit there is
there's i think it's like if um
if he gave me something i think i would
leave yeah like like an std or something
or like
if um
it became like public you know i mean
like he was doing it so much like
everyone knows you know
um
i don't know i'd have to think more
about it there is a line but i'm saying
if it's like a one-time thing
like i don't know men and women are
different and you you would stay with
them
if that would work out if i had kids i
would try to work it out
i would give him probably a chance yeah
i think everyone does mistakes and
nobody's perfect
but
more than once no i would cheat around
him on purpose then my idea actually
wait wait
wait
wait
you have to pay the same price
you pay you pay for apple i give you an
apple okay that's it with me
well what happened here no no no well
you realize that that lowers your value
like you're kind of playing yourself
because like you're just saying oh i'm
for the stream
as well like forgiving so many times
this guy who cheated on you all the time
so just because you have a kid i mean i
don't want my kids to be raised by a guy
that is a cheater because even just
being but then then he'll be raised by
two cheaters
[Laughter]
yeah i was speaking on your behalf okay
okay no no no no
go ahead go ahead i would never accept
that to come back to my life okay
never you know never you've never done
that no i've never been cheated not that
i know i mean um so yeah
and let's pray for him if he cheated on
me and i know i'll go back to my ex and
then probably i will cheat around him
but i don't have no kids i can do it
no i'm joking okay anyway
don't keep talking keep talking
okay okay so
you would if you were me i was you
the relationship we have a kid and he
cheated on me
okay i would forgive him once but twice
huh you're dumb
i just
i'm just like okay
hello
you're giving him more of an example to
follow okay
if i was you okay yeah first time
yeah i for if i was you okay okay the
first time you cheated on me okay i
forgive you god forgive you too okay
we have a kid okay family let's let's
have a happy family second time oh
i will show you how to cheat then
i will invite him i actually imagined
these in my head you know
better let her go i will call him hey
baby let's go to the hotel
you know five stars
not not two stars and no motel okay i
bring the handcuffs you know oh handcuff
okay i i'm like yeah let's play kinky
right okay
[Music]
the best looking guy i find you know and
then i [ __ ] him
my husband whatever it is wait but we'd
say you would you wouldn't
you would okay okay let me let me just
let me just let me just get this
straight let me oh he feels what i felt
not just once but twice uh
darling okay let me let me let me just
unders i don't know one i feel like the
guy would probably leave
that's good okay
second second
second second you realize like
okay
this is what we mean by girls cheat
worse
bringing us back to the beginning
you see what i mean
i never cheat on no one okay
oh my god
[Music]
okay
but how does that help you
a lot
no how does that that guy the ego is
gonna be more little than his penis
you have to be careful don't cheat on my
girl you know
okay
okay but yeah
okay but you really
he's just gonna look at you like you're
a hoe oh you're gonna hold that oh
okay a guy cheats
okay so a guy he cheats he's a hero he's
not a hoe and if we forgive no no he
comes home ah baby
okay because because then she cheats
she's a whole yes
yes
yes girl yes yes and i and i understand
that men and women are different like
what do they say
yeah there's a love like it's the same
thing if he cheats on me i do that i'm
not just i'm not a cheater yeah i would
do that in the first place right i'm
saying on your behalf if you're okay if
you were me
that's what you would do if i had a
cheater okay i would never accept him
back even if i had 10 children i would
make him pay for the 10 children yeah
you would help me you know like come you
know with the money being present at
their life at their events and their
parties all that at school you know all
that
but living with me
that's like
no that's calling myself every day dumb
are you dumb
no i'm dumb
no
no you gotta talk into the money it's a
lot for me so no but i was saying on
your behalf okay if he cheats on me once
i forgive surprise twice then okay so
let me let me just i just wanna i wanna
let me let me start let me recap okay so
that was a lot
that was a lot let me let me
okay let me let me just recap here okay
okay okay guys guys
okay okay let me recap okay one
so he cheats on you once you say we'll
work it out for the kids
okay
then he cheats on you a second time your
solution is to get a really good looking
guy of course to screw you in front of
him yeah something that can be fun
what's what's up with that
okay yeah
and
um
and then you leave him off and he'll
tell all his friends
do you know i can tell whatever i don't
care you know in the end of the day i
know who i am and he's been the cheater
like since day one he like he started
the cheating game you know
you're left with 10 kids an extra body
and no one to look after you but that's
the thing i'm saying
on this situation on her behalf not me
yeah because she would she would leave
immediately
she's [ __ ] putting all of that
[Music]
she's just she's just giving me some
advice you know
she's just
thank you for the
i clap for these fifty dollar super chat
oh my god i keep dropping my phone today
i'm sorry guys as a man i'm expected to
protect provide security discipline and
finances the least my would-be wife
could do is not embarrass me
embarrassing me by not by
not showing assets on social media no no
man wants to pay full money for a car
that has been ridden by his peers true
okay next
how do i okay wait pull it down
um okay the next one another one from
sentience 20 super chat to the female
guest in black if you have a children
and as you age you will relegate
yourself to accepting a cheater because
if he provided money and security you
would be content and sharing him
especially as the attention drops what
do you think of that
so so she's saying as you're older you
wouldn't have as many options so as you
get older and
he's saying that if he's providing like
if he's paying for everything you would
deal with it
he can still pay and be out of the house
you know you can pay because we still
have the kid in common right right yeah
but i don't do you guys think that a
dude would pay for a house he's not
living in no you can get child support
yeah so so if he's taking care of all of
your bills right and you have 10 kids
your option now is to leave and be alone
because you're older
or stay with him and work it out and
like you would also be poor and alone or
maybe you take half i guess i think
realistically i understand where you're
coming from but i think realistically
you would stay
because are you going to end up in the
streets with 10 kids no
you want to stay
like if i mean i'm very independent and
if you have a good job as a woman as
well you can have kids still and being
working i don't know if i would have 10
kids but
depends on the situation depending on
your financial situation as a woman as
well you know even though it you cannot
just depend on a man that's the thing
like even if the man provides even more
than you never like
like how you say settle
for like the the situation of like oh my
god now i can raise the family and be
jobless you know no never otherwise oh
why that's great for kids
that's amazing actually then you know to
be there 24 7. yeah definitely but if
you give up on all that and that happens
like if the guy cheats on her right you
are like indeed what do you like you are
do you want to live your life out of
fear though
like is that how you want to live your
life because things could go wrong for
my kids
okay okay wait let me let me let me wait
i cannot leave my cheetahs i cannot live
with people who lie who are fake i'm
[ __ ] real i cannot just live with
people like i wouldn't if i if i live
with a cheater probably i would see
myself every day in my mind like
thinking how to kill him how to
you know honestly okay i am latina no i
don't know i my blood
we can tell
it's like boiling it boils you know okay
i would like think probably how to cut
his penis so in so many ways
you know to sell on amazon something
like that
okay okay okay but if a girl but if a
guy says that right if a guy says what
if what if a guy said she cheated so i'm
gonna cut her tits off do you think put
it on amazon
no i mean
i'm just saying i cannot leave with the
cheetah i couldn't live with the cheater
no i'm not saying that i would do that
i'm just saying
that if i had
the thinking of like leaving with a
cheater that that would be the thoughts
that i would have about okay
i'm not a killer but what you what you
said about never depending on a man you
don't think it's a good idea for a girl
to be a stay-at-home mom
like if she has the option to do that
even i would love to you know yeah
when it comes like to have the the child
like as a woman you have like three
months i don't know in the uk though
mm-hmm like three months i'd like to
like the father to have that those three
months at least you know to be with the
child as well you know i think they put
a lot on
on the female
perspective like oh she should stay with
the kid but father not as much you know
uh i think it should be like equality on
that but yeah i mean when it comes to
she should do something otherwise if
this happens how can you live with a
person well it just that's like just
that's a fear mentality though that's a
fear like there are a lot of like
stay-at-home moms that homeschool their
kids and that's really good for kids
that's real yeah i mean if you can do
that definitely yeah right but i'm just
saying but you'd have to depend on a man
to do that you know what i mean yeah and
so like i just think a lot of times we
kind of have this rhetoric that we like
can't depend on men but when men don't
leave most of the time
like men again men only leave 30 of the
time
college-educated women it's it's 10.
so it's just um it just seems like
maybe that was like something that
happened just because your parents got
divorced you kind of put that on your
future relationships yeah probably yeah
childhood trauma it kind of got me there
yeah that show
um and it's something i need to heal and
i don't want to project that on my
future relationships not even in a
friendship way no at all
but it's i'm just like
thinking and imagining all these things
that could happen yeah your imagination
goes wild i'm not an actress so i i kind
of have like that imagination process
yeah you're like very active which is
amazing but yeah i need to don't get
scared guys okay i'm not here
no we're good we love him
okay okay um i have some more super
chats i'm gonna read um mentality like
that in the black suit is exactly why
men of value
um is exactly what men of value that
most women are after will avoid because
the person personification and
liability and heartache thank you for
showing the high value man oh gosh
that um
they're not interested
they're just saying yeah the okay next
one is
okay i think is that the last one
sometimes it doesn't refresh did i miss
any before
okay
i i think that zentians was the last one
i read
okay but that was 50 so
[Applause]
[Music]
two more
um okay do you want to read them if you
can because i don't think i see them
i have a producer guys how cool is this
wait read the last one just yeah it was
was the last one um from zentiance it
was 50 and it starts with mentality like
okay okay
that's what i was asking if that was the
last one
okay cool um okay so
um don't cheat on her
um
don't cheat on anyone just
but especially
i would just leave
and you know for not to cheat on me like
i think we are human like we like to
experience different things and after a
while you get bored with the same person
in a way like sexually sometimes and
because i've been in relationship for
seven years and i know that and
even though you love that person he gets
a bed sometimes
but that's why you spice it up like at
the end of the day it's your moment
what's your man in the relationship so
then the cheating doesn't happen
cheating here is actually
you being with someone that your person
doesn't know that you are with because
you are not being honest so so you guys
open relationships out there and they
actually worked so so if you said okay
it's getting a bit boring the sex is
getting a bit boring you bla ah
add this guy in a little bit spice it up
so basically i'm a
like i'm a believer of love and i love
romance and i love all that and for me i
would like to build a relationship with
someone for the first at least three
years let's say that it's just me and
him and after we both feel that kind of
you say you're allowed to get with this
person you're allowed to get a disposal
i probably would share or probably do
something different you know like just
to spice it up sometimes not that it
would be an everyday order so like three
so like three sums
so you're saying like that's what it
sounds like fine i never done it but
yeah i'm open to it if but after a
relationship is built with with honesty
loyalty for at least like three four
years okay and then after we if we both
feel like the sex is not
wow like before and he's getting to a
place that is just like oh okay we
find ways like
both way i mean we both find ways to
spice it up it doesn't have to be with
someone else or probably it has to be
somewhere else i don't know but i'm just
saying i'm open to ideas you're open so
you'd be open to an open relationship uh
and after i built that
that bond and that trust and that but
what do you want with the trust when
it's an open relationship because you're
not breaking the trust once you are
being opened what do you feel and what
you're saying so it's not about doing
that because if you do behind your back
behind the person that you are with then
that's cheating because cheating it's
not being loyal
you're saying it's not cheating because
you know they're having sex with that
person so because because you've
witnessed it or you you know about it
it's not cheating because yeah because
she has a point there though she's
saying if i am saying this is an open
relationship and he agrees
and he tells me about these people then
it's not cheating because exactly we've
said it's an open relationship because i
would never but i i understand where
she's coming from it's not cheating but
it's going to be doomed to fail i think
if you just look at the most public
example now will smith has got jaydon
is going through it there's something up
for a man about another another man
[ __ ] your wife yeah your girlfriend
that how am i gonna be sitting at home
playing fifa and you're like oh yeah
baby we'll be late tonight
i know you'll get your back blown out i
have to sit there online with my friends
like
pass me the ball
if you really love someone can you share
them though them never nope ever
you can't really if you really love that
person or you unless you're high value
no well that's that you're somewhat true
though i mean how many one-sided open
relationships do you see it with the
ultra wealthy men like nba players yeah
drake did a whole song about their side
chicks in front of them but people
classify themselves as value as high
value and then they cheat is that a high
value well it's about no no it's about
supply but again it's about supply and
demand right so so for those guys like
the guys that like let's take nba
players right
there's a dime and a dozen pretty women
like they can get a pretty woman that
can cook they can get a pretty latina
they can get a pretty black girl like
whatever their type is they could they
could have them all they could have
multiple girlfriends because everybody
wants them
they're like the epitome same with like
movie stars and that
so it's it's when i think of high value
i just think the guys that are most in
demand
and they're in demand from everybody
like like take you okay how how much
does a guy have to make to date you
he has to have a job right yeah like not
like your friend because i have one too
so i'm not gonna live by my money
but uh yeah he has to be ambitious he
has to be responsible he has to be
he has to know the worth of money okay
so how much money 45k
too much too little
it's okay 45k is okay yeah it's good and
how tall does he have to be taller than
me for sure okay so i feel like i'm
dating a minion okay
and he has to be good looking too right
in shape
he takes care of himself yeah he likes
he's hygienic like he likes you know to
go to the gym it cannot be like it
doesn't need to be like a nerd you know
like
can you say a gym nerd
um
gym rat chimera
yeah
yeah i mean but likes to take care of
himself because i do that too so we have
to have that in common otherwise i think
it would be a little bit
so guys um how much money does a girl
have to make to date you she could be in
the streets right now
she can be sleeping right there as long
as she's beautiful i will bring her up
i'll
i'll bring her
okay so another question how tall does
she have to be any height cause i'm six
foot five so don't matter
for me for me i'll say about five
yeah
i'm tired of giving these five two girls
my like my energy
like i'm a king i can't do it anymore
actually to be honest i love five two
girls maybe i don't know any high any
height anyhow okay um how attractive one
to ten oh they have to be fine okay they
have to be fine yeah they have to be
so outside of looks what else
oh that have good character good
character like as in because
if you're dating for like a long time
yeah like marriage or like
kids
that's the person that's going to raise
your kids so you could be a 10 but if
your character is dead
so yeah your character has to be your
character
that's what jam means
i feel like
money-wise i i don't care like i really
don't care but character-wise is more
important that's yeah i feel like for
men you you fall in
well what initially attracts you is
obviously their looks and then once you
get to know them once you get to know
that you can bring their looks down
yeah
and also bring them up as well like it
lets you kind of stay with them
that's what we really care about just
looks and looks personal
i don't know for me culturally like i
know it's going to sound in 2022 it
sounds it sounds mad and i know it
sounds bad but the whole
cooking thing like a woman that can't
for me culturally because i'm african
african man
a woman that can't cook i'm sorry like
i've dated girls and been like oh yeah i
can't cook let's get take out my in my
head i'm not
this is not gonna go far but okay like
and the thing is i don't need you to
cook i could i can cook it together we
can work but it's just like culturally
i need someone i can't lie i don't care
if they can't cook i don't care like i
need this don't get taken away
no i do they just need to be very pretty
in it and it's hard to find pretty girls
so that's already like loosening the
shortening the pool in it you know it's
interesting men swipe right on dating
apps around fifty percent of the time
fifty percent you actually think it's
hard to find pretty women out there
today
yeah
well then you must have a very specific
type yeah i do yeah exactly that's why
you find it why are you
five two
five two five five two i'll just say i
don't care about it
it's the curly hair and it's like middle
eastern
so like a female version of you a little
bit i'm not middle eastern
i like middle eastern
i'm selective i'm very selective i can't
lie
do you feel like most men are selected
no um most men know
my friends yes
yeah yeah
um i think i think my point is though
like like it's just different because in
general like like women have a long list
of [ __ ] that they want and men don't
and like so when they say high value
they're just talking about the men that
like girls want like you know
there's different studies so i i don't
know the exact number but between like
five and twenty percent of men on dating
apps get all of the likes and some
people say it's as little as five
percent they get eighty percent of the
likes sorry
and then the the because like most girls
want guys who are like over six foot but
they don't realize it's actually
not common for guys to be over six foot
it's like they want all these diff
specific categories like there's only a
few guys
that fit all their needs
or yeah it's like the curse of being
tall as a girl yeah
yeah it's like
but i like to be taller and change i
love being tall too me too
but
i don't care if a guy's like close but
i i can't if it's too much i can't do it
yeah i can't i feel you how tall are you
uh 5 11. are we the same height 179
well i'm 5 11. i don't know what it is
in centimeters okay we will check yeah i
didn't i didn't realize you were that
different taller than me okay okay yeah
um
okay um
what
have any of you had any crazy cheating
stories or like social media even if
it's just a friend
are you laughing
what's funny i'm just trying to filter
you what's funny
okay go ahead he has a few
go ahead like when you say crazy what do
you mean
like that that cheating
i don't know just
you you know you're laughing tell the
story
um
okay there was one where a friend who
had cheated on his partner quite a lot
um
basically which friend name him
um yeah where he went to a house party
after him and his girl got back together
and
he like he loved that girl like he told
us all the time was like yeah this thing
i'm gonna marry
and then
he gets his house party now
he i was with him he was like he was on
his best behavior
and but there was a girl with us and
then they were just like chilling
whatever having having a laugh
and then by the end of the night because
he was waved
and then he was like oh yeah yeah we're
gonna get the same cab home because like
she's going in my direction i'm gonna
hop out
and then i'm looking in like big muscle
blinds me just go in the cab man
okay
yeah
turns out in the morning he calls us
guys
i didn't beat it i didn't
he still did other stuff but he was so
happy with himself they didn't beat he's
like i've changed i've changed i didn't
wait but he did others
with him but he still cheated
he was like because i'm a changed man i
love my girlfriend oh no way
i love her i love her
oh my god he didn't register that he
still cheated on his girlfriend yeah
because that's so sad
he
saw he saw when he saw him turning down
having sex with that girl i was like
okay clearly i can't do this anymore i
need to go back to any week he was sorry
he was so excited like when he called us
on the group chat so excited are they
still together oh god no
did she find out
i'm actually not sure how it's awesome
tomorrow okay
how many girls did he do that with like
too many
like more more than you could count um
the ones i saw a lot was he really good
looking
he was all right you know
okay
but i think the
okay you know
men they're not that good looking they
are actually the ones who cheat more
that's what i heard there's not even the
good lookings like the hard ones how do
you know that because i know some
friends they had that experience here
and in portugal like their ugly
boyfriends was cheating on yeah which is
like funny it's really
um okay do you think
that
um oh i asked this earlier but i don't
know if you guys responded who do you
think cheats more men are women just go
around everyone women women men
men
men women
men earlier i said women didn't they i'm
sure you said that you said
did i say that
i know this that's going to be women or
something yeah
i was the only guy in my in my like flat
and i saw some wild literally
just delinquency
i think women cheat in different ways so
i think women will accept like a guy's
time attention and resources while in a
relationship yeah so she'll have like
guy friends that like clearly want to
bang her
like and just like put them in the
friend zone
and i think that's like a form of like
like what's the joke what's funny you're
you're right
you're right is that what you do yeah no
like because i think i feel like girls
we always know
if like a guy wants to hundred percent
hundred percent
we just yeah pretend like i've got loads
of guy friends so then when you have
something
and then you tell that boyfriend that ah
he's just a friend in your head you know
that
okay so i think that's that's a
different form of cheating or like girls
will accept
like flirt with guys a little bit more
because they can to be honest or like
i've seen girls like at bars like like
twerking on another dude i'm like okay
but
[Music]
it's equal about um men do but two
percent more so it's like 25 percent one
serving yeah two percent more but i i
have an inkling that women do it more
they just don't get caught to be honest
because oh my god i have a story i've
told this story before in the podcast
but i'm gonna tell it again this girl
have you ever noticed that
i'm
curious if the women like girls will
date a new guy
but still be in love with the ex
have you yeah yeah have you noticed that
i've never been in a relationship but
you've never been in a relationship
okay but like um
maybe like your friends like they'll
date a new guy but still be in love with
the guy they had a situation with or
even though they're with some some
someone new i would never know yeah so
one situation i could think of in
college was this girl and you would
never know she wasn't a big drinker she
wasn't a big party she didn't put her
ass on the internet you would never know
she kind of she looks like you're like
girl next door like very very nice girl
and freshman year of college she was
with this one guy okay
and they would they would like hook up
for like a month okay then he was just a
player he was like
five
seven
so i didn't know why she was like
tripping
and
it'd be one thing if he had like any
ambition or drive or anything more to
offer i didn't get it like i just did
not get it but anyways she was obsessed
with this man he dumps her right a
couple years later she's dating
this new guy he's really nice like
honestly he bought her a house she moves
her into
bought our house they're living together
in this house okay
and there was a party senior year of
college
and um i i'm at this like dardy i'm like
you know i'm shimmying it's like a good
day like it's like
and i i i'm like it's weird i haven't
seen her in a minute the guy the
boyfriend's not there okay
and
i see her walk out of the bathroom
with the guy from freshman year at that
party
and then yeah
and like because i hadn't seen her in
like a half hour you know what i'm
saying and so then later that boyfriend
comes to the party
ah no way no and i just knowing her i
don't think she would have put that she
cheated on that survey
if she was surveyed on it yeah because
that's what i mean that survey is not
going to be that accurate because no i
feel like oh did you cheat people are
going to lie and say they didn't when
they have yeah no it can't be accurate
yeah it can't be a cause how would you
and i haven't taken that subway so who
did they get that survey from that
i don't know actually not off the top of
my head i can tell you that they didn't
survey every single person so no i think
they just they do it like it's a general
representation of the population
something like that but yeah that's my
crazy cheating story that's like i feel
like
i think guys don't go out of their way
to search
if their girls cheat most guys don't go
out the way if they girls cheating if
they think that if they think that girls
cheating more time they're just going to
go cheat themselves
they're not the words of god if a girl
thinks their man is cheating she's going
to go out
into sherlock holmes immediately and
she's going to find out everything dates
phone numbers surnames second class
that's like sound girl's name that's so
crazy i would never do that
i would never
so it's just like
yeah guys guys have a different reaction
to that i would say do you okay do you
think that in a relationship you should
have each other's passcodes and
passwords no no i've no if you've got
done it
yeah i've i've done it um
at a certain point i was like you know
what i have nothing to hide like
i don't care like you
but i've done that in the sense of if my
phone if if i need you set an alarm on
my phone do it it's
i don't think people should be going
through their partner's phone yes
exactly i feel like it could be open
yeah but then if they're using your
if they're looking for your phone just
because you two are together just
looking through photos but then if
they're looking for the fact that
they're searching to see oh did he
message this girl they're looking to see
are you cheating that's why they're
trying they're trying to find something
that's maybe not even there it's like
but at the same time you don't think
sometimes the girls have like intuition
and
then they're searching for it you might
not even be
cheating or whatever and it's gonna make
it's gonna negatively impact the
relationship i just think we need to get
rid of it all together i had a girl go
through my phone after seven days
seven days that's super even through my
phone
oh it's just a story in it
um like
so
long story short i must have logged into
like i don't know just eat or delivery
or something okay
and it's i think it saved my password so
when she was going to log into instagram
for some she saw it saved my stuff
and then she just clicked it went
through my whole dm so after seven days
seven days that's crazy crazy i think if
you're married you should have each
other's passions
i do think if you're married i don't
think in a relationship so much but if
you're married
like you shouldn't have anything to hide
if you're married that's what i mean if
you've got nothing to hide then why not
but like i think at the other end you
don't want to be like obsessive to where
you're always like like you need your
although everything's shared and you're
together you need your personal space
yeah yeah yeah yeah you do
you need to be separate otherwise you
can be too clingy
yeah yeah and i think like every time
i've been in a situation where i want to
like look through a guy's phone like
it's because like i shouldn't be with
the guy
100 yeah it's like i shouldn't be with
him to begin with yes
if you're together you're like okay not
a lot together if you're married you're
basically
at that point you become one person
you you have yourself
but really and truly you are one person
at that point
so
just the thought of having something the
other person can't access
at all is kind because think of it like
a bank account
if you're married and you've been
married for like 10 years and the other
person has no access to a certain bank
account is that is that is that not
weird
yeah yeah yeah that's weird right
your partner can't actually
so okay ten years three kids and there's
something
there's a folder on a computer that
there's a password i don't know what
no no no
there shouldn't be any secrets basically
yeah yeah do you okay so um fresh or
some super chats okay let me see let me
see
um okay
can i
let me see if i can read them some of
them i think are gone
um okay i got
five pounds from jay yeah i was living
with this girl who started making more
than me monthly only because her parents
paid all of her bills and she started
acting as if i'm jobless
but yeah i'm sorry that happened to you
that's
um mgtow by logic ten dollars shout out
to straight man in the chat say hi to
your mom for me that was the last one
those two okay
um i forgot the question i was gonna ask
oh so on the fresh and fit show
um so the way myron looks at it
is he says that he
that so basically the girl is cheating
if they have instagram which maybe is
too far okay
but like he he wants these like
one-sided open relationships where like
the guy can cheat and the girl can't
wow so basically like and fresh was
saying on the show that he wants to have
access to the girl's instagram
but he she doesn't get access to hers
yeah that's like being stupid
like narcissist do you think entitled
narcissism
honestly
oh
yeah but you can't let me change well
okay but you don't think cheating's
different for men and for women
i mean
[ __ ] is the same thing for both sides
i don't
i don't did you miss the conversation we
had earlier but i think regardless
saying like who do you think you are
like actually you're not like who do you
actually think you are you wouldn't
change anything if you had all of your
bills taken care of the rest of your
life you'd never have to work again
and then you can cheat and yeah yeah so
you just have to hello yeah i don't know
yeah so like no so he would have rules
with the cheating okay so this is the
rules would be no stds no outside kids
no one would ever find out about it no
you would never find out about it like
you he would never put it in your face
so you you essentially
yeah yeah yeah so this is upfront you
know so
i love love
so for me it's the emotional part like i
cannot imagine my man being with someone
else at all i don't care
you know they say love is a young
person's game
because when you get older it gets more
practical
and when you're and when you're
so women you need
the reason women have to get married is
because they need to get 2.5 million to
retire like people need 2.5 million in
the bank account to retire it's very
hard to do that off of one income
so i feel like the
that's the idea of marriage and
relationships love is not
love is not like a social construct like
love is
it's like
deeper than people think so you can fall
in love but
with someone else but because this guy
is more stable whatever you're going to
go with the more stable guy but
love is like uncontrollable like you
can't really like contain it i don't
i've just never thought love was enough
like love love isn't enough for our
marriage
[Music]
and like
occupation and like upbringing as well
culture like so many things come into it
like marriage is a contract at the end
of the day i mean it's not like i love
you so much
your partner so you're going into
is not enough
well said very well said yeah no i
actually i agree with you i think that's
the reason a lot of relationships fail
today is it's all based on yes like how
we feel and like the exciting guy you
know like that's and it comes to an end
very soon
yeah because i mean
if you want to have like kids and a
family you only have so long to like
pick one exactly
so but it's interesting
what do you think people base their
partners on like in like what makes you
say that
because i think okay so this comes
this is
this stems from a conversation i had
with a friend about
interracial dating okay and i'm all for
loving who you want dating who you want
but my thought process came from the
fact that is people don't understand the
things that come with it
so
a lot of a lot of them end
abruptly
from what i've seen close close around
to me because a lot of people get into
it based on initial attraction and like
we get along but then
over a couple of years it's like okay
well
the nuances come into it from different
different things within their culture
and then it's like okay so we touched on
this small thing
this morning and those small things
start to add up so yeah as i said love
isn't enough you can still love that
person
end of the day yes not going to work
because so many little things
yes you did not think about beforehand
yes you think love is going to solve all
the world's problems
well and it's and it's and it's
very important
was going to say so
so what you're basically saying is you
can fall in love with anyone but you
can't be in a relationship with anyone
100 yeah yeah 100 right wow
when you fell in love like i think you
need to be friends you know and like
start to imagine what kind of life you
would have with that person like you
know i think status and who they are
even though you have feelings for that
person you need to know like go be
realistic
because would you see yourself with
someone who has no job has no
i mean has no
career has no ambition and then you want
to you know it changes the whole picture
change the whole picture like you cannot
you know all by yourself and my love but
so i think we should be very careful
before we fall in love i think we should
be always first like friends
and then see if we have a future with
that person there's one issue with the
whole friend thing though
and i'm actually i've always thought
that it's like all right let's be
friends first
but at the same time it's like all right
so i have to be your friend while you're
out here
[Music]
i don't um so just make sure you're
going really close okay okay
um
okay tell me if that's better in the
chat guys i know you guys are saying
everyone in black is echoing so i think
so make sure you're just going like
really close to the mic when we talk
um okay so
tell me
um okay so we were talking about
relationships and why they fail
do you think social media is one of the
reasons relationships fail yes
100 you'd say it's the biggest reason
probably why
just the whole grass is greener thing
everyone's always seeing
different guys like i remember even
going from my tick tock tick tock is
demon i go through my for you page maybe
it's my specific algorithm i don't know
but it's just girl
it's based on what it is
yeah
it's the busted challenge
yeah but
it got put in front of me in the first
place for me to have looked at it do you
know what i mean i don't type in hot
girls no but you like the ones
you got in front of me
yeah the phone does listen to you phones
but that's another conversation oh yeah
listen it got initially put in front of
me i liked it and now it just keeps
coming up tick tock is good for that
because it knows it's like it knows what
so what you spend more time watching or
what you're liking or what you're
commenting it'll recommend more videos
like for that so like whatever's coming
up on your feed is what you enjoy the
most obviously it's not just that but
like
that's there as well that's what i'm
trying to say but it's just the
temptation element
that like you know what i mean the grass
is green i think as i said at the
beginning i think it's more for girls
because i feel like guys once they
finally go on and everything they just
kind of settle and they're good
[Music]
you know what i mean though like the
guys don't leave the guys don't leave
they don't leave but that doesn't mean
they cheat
have you guys ever cheated i have no
comment oh uh
why that's honest oh that's very honest
i'm not happy with myself for doing it
because
the reaction of the person when they
found out
killed me right so yeah yeah actually
how'd she find out
oh she went sherlock on the internet
why are you mumbling bro
close to your mic
full detective mode and and just and
actually
no she didn't i just messed up i was i
was uh i'm not going to say sloppy that
sounds weird but i was i was like
i just messed up and then she found out
um but yeah yeah i think it was the
reaction um seeing that reaction someone
else is just like
uh she probably shouldn't do that again
it hurt you seeing them probably you're
still thinking probably i mean no one
knows what the future holds but
in five years let alone five minutes so
like
self-control
and about no i understand where he's
coming from though you can never say
yeah
so but yeah um
yeah cheating is a wild one
you shouldn't do it what girls have you
cheated i haven't been in a relationship
you've ever cheated no never it's
interesting like guys will admit it
girls won't
i've never i've never i've asked
i've asked a lot of girls on this
platform if they've ever cheated and
i've asked a lot of guys how many of
them said yes never girl really they
would never say no it's like you said
like girls and guys define cheating
those different things like
someone could say oh liking a picture is
cheating whereas
but also it's like i feel like it's also
self-preservation
because if they come out and say oh yeah
i've cheated a guy might look at them
differently and well a bunch of guys
might look at them differently not
pursue them whereas as a guy
i can be honest because like i'm i'm
like i'm all about self-improvement and
all that
but like at the end of the day i'm the
one pursuing it so you can you can say
no i believe in my source a girl is not
pursuing
that isn't pursuing man
so like
she knows if i if i admit this then
that's going to reduce my selection
mm-hmm you know i mean so they're never
really gonna i don't think it really
affects like how do i put it like girl
guys the same if they admit to cheating
then a girl is like well at least he's
honest
so i was like well at least she admitted
to it
we're a guy like that she's for the
streets
she's like we could rationalize stuff
like i swear to god sometimes guys be
telling us that they're red flags
they'll tell you and we'll just be like
well he told us
he was honest you guys think they can
change you black oh i don't want to know
how i don't want any of that stuff i'm
going to do this like
oh it's fine that's fine
yeah they'll try and change we're going
to be pictured
we're trying to fix things okay
there's a couple more super chats um
let's see
um okay 10.
oh wait i read that one already okay um
[Music]
guys i'm i'm trying to fix the echo i
think it might i'm not sure what the
issue is tonight but
i think it's just people not being close
enough to their mics possibly we're
gonna we're gonna get some new mic
stands soon so this this will go away in
the next show
or two i don't know um okay no fresh and
fit myron is worth about two million
dollars walter weeks is worth about one
to three million dollars that's about
point zero five percent of the us
population so they have leverage
um five dollars from the abc one two
three four five six three and nine nine
damn pearl don't that damn pearl them
legs is everything do you squat i do
i do
thank you for noticing
i've been in the gym thank you
um okay uh i think we're gonna kind of
close out the show though on that so why
don't we go around and you guys can say
any final thoughts this has been a
really great group so um i appreciate
all of you guys for coming appreciate
you having us thank you so much so go
around say your
name um your instagram any links that
you want to plug
and oh actually um he has a really great
podcast that you guys should follow
um
and
yeah where they can find you
yeah my name is ollie uh my instagram is
ollie engelay that's o-l-y-e-n-g-e-l-e
and i've got a podcast uh called
shambles fm comedy podcast we cover all
like social topics uh dayton celebrity
culture
um stuff like that we're on tick tock
spotify apple podcast
anywhere youtube everywhere just
shambles a film
in family and i was i was on their last
episode i don't know when it's coming
out uh your episode is coming out not
next week the week after yeah so in two
weeks i'm gonna have gone on their
podcast and they're really funny like
it's actually very entertaining so you
guys are too soon
part two
i'm not a youtuber but i'm thinking to
become one
you should definitely do it
give this girl a mike
give this girl a mine
i'll think about it for sure
yeah my name is troy um my instagram is
troy
waters9 um i was thinking about doing my
own podcast as well like talking about
football and things like that
um so yeah i'm just learning from the
pros actually but yeah
yeah you can find me on instagram um
it's p-a-r-v-a
r
and i think um the most interesting
thing today was what you said that love
isn't enough because i've always been
like trying to explain that feeling
but you just put it like perfectly so
yeah
yeah my name is telvin uh instagram's
television that's t-e-l-v-i-n jacob
find me on youtube as well why not
find me on youtube as well um tj's world
t-e-e-j-a-y-s
world i'm on tick-tock everything pretty
much yeah
okay also guys um we just launched merch
so um if you guys want to get your own
the pre-game t-shirt it's in the
description you can see there's like
t-shirts there's also a t-shirt for the
men called ask me about my rotation so
if you want to show women that you've
been pre-selected
are you gonna get one
okay guys um thank you so much for
watching um i really couldn't do it
without you guys and all the super